20:17 a study in BMC psychiatry found 31
percent of girls and young women have
symptoms of anxiety compared to 13
percent of boys and young men
psychologist and CBS News contributor
Lisa d'amour addresses the growing issue
in her new book it's called under
pressure confronting the epidemic of
stress and anxiety in girls Lisa good
morning good morning so for those of us
who have young girls this is an acute
topic why is it an epidemic what's
changed to make it such a big problem
well girls have always been more anxious
than boys when we look at the diagnostic
rates but we are watching those numbers
rise and we are watching them rise
faster in girls than in boys and there
are unique pressures the girls face they
worry more about school they worry more
about disappointing adults they are
achieving unbelievable things these days
and yet they know they are still judged
heavily on how they look so I'm just
gonna do all the things I do wrong and
worrying about disappointing adults yes
the solution to that is not to say oh
don't worry we're not disappointed
because they don't hear that right or is
that am I wrong about they don't hear
that I think they read our faces I think
that you know our girls know us really
well so we have to be mindful of the
messages we send whether we mean to or
not but I think the way we should look
at it is that those messages are
powerful we can make anxiety and stress
much worse for our daughters or much
better when they are very stressed and
anxious sometimes we then get stressed
and anxious and what I want parents to
remember is what they did instinctively
when their toddler girls skinned her
knee mm-hmm because you know like
toddlers fall down and the first thing
they do is they look at you they look at
their knee and then they look at you
yeah and if you are calm even if you're
panicking inside they're okay and if you
are panicking they are panicking so our
job is to take that up into later
childhood and adolescence and when they
are panicking we stay calm and we say
it's gonna be okay we'll figure this out
you mentioned that girls are anxious
about how they look and I'm wondering if
that also starts from a young age when
parents innocently say you're so
beautiful look how cute you are
you look adorable is there too much
focus
unintentionally on how a girl looks from
an early age well the culture is all
about girls looks so even if parents are
careful at home they're up against a
culture that sends a very powerful
message but of course with our daughters
like oh you're so cute you're so
charming and even if you're not cute and
sure I look at some old pictures of me
and I remember and I'm not saying we
can't say that but what we have to
remember is we are focusing on the most
superficial aspect of that girl and the
one over which she has the least control
so when we are talking about girls looks
we are not talking about how creative
and clever and interesting they are and
I think about it almost like a zero-sum
game we can talk about one or we can
talk about the other and we talk about
the first one a lot these the
communication is so important but what
if you were at the stage I've heard
about this in families where your
daughter is not necessarily listening to
anything you have to say well I think
they hear more than we think they do and
what I find is that reassurance tends
not to work as well as we think it will
and what does work is validation so when
girls are having a hard time my favorite
two words are stinks and handle so we
say you know what that stinks that does
it stinks and then we say I think it's
in the category of what you can handle
and I'm here to help you handle it
rather than saying it's gonna be okay I
like I think that's very good advice you
you also talked about girls friendships
which I thought was very interesting you
said girls friendships are supposed to
make life better but it can make it
worse
and it really comes down to numbers you
said so we think it's great to have a
whole bunch of friends but when you look
at it numbers bring drama there's no
getting around it and the reason for
that is that it is impossible to get
five human beings of any age who like
one another equally and yet seventh
graders attempt this so you say keep to
one or two really good friends will make
a big difference
stressed kids have one or two really
good friends because it's reliable and
the drama is low which isn't to say you
have to then fire certain friends from
your daughter's friend group it's just
to recognize that the stress is sort of
built into how
arranged themselves it's not that
anyone's being unusually caddy or
difficult and girls need a verbal
toolkit you said I thought this was
fascinating qalaat about how we instruct
girls to speak and we do say you know be
bold be outgoing be forthright and I
think that's some of what we need to
advise but that's not going to work in
every situation communication is so
complex and so context driven so I like
to think of equipping girls with a
verbal toolkit so every girl needs a
hammer for certain situations but they
should also have tweezers and other ways
to make things happen give me one
sentence in a verbal toolkit in less
than 10 seconds would you mind if I came
over later and we hung out as opposed to
I'm coming over there okay write that
they needles they need both yes and they
need this book we'll be right back Lisa
thank you so much thank you